All right, it's time for Drew's News,
your comfy, oversized, good news sweater.
And with me at the desk, my main thread, Ross Mathews.
Yes, hi everybody. (crowd cheers and claps)
Hi. Hi Drew.
(crowd cheers and claps) (Ross laughs)
I love this outfit.
Yeah, I took a risk today.
Pattern on pattern, but it's Design Week, hello.
It's giving me all the feels and we're both in vests.
Yeah, we are vest dressed.
We are vest dressed.
Yeah, and I am invested in our looks today. (laughs)
Oh, invested, come on.
Come on, I know.
God, that was good.
You are the king of puns
and you just warm the cockles of my heart when you do it.
Oh, thanks. (crowd laughs)
And I'm really excited because beyond Design Week,
it is International Women's Day.
Yeah. (crowd cheers and claps) Yes.
Today is the day to celebrate women
all around the world that have achieved
that often totally against the odds, you know, accolades.
And it's also a day to focus on
how we can break down all the biases around us
and even get closer to gender equality.
And People magazine is doing just that,
celebrating with their special
Women Changing the World issue.
Check out our cover girl, Lizzo.
Yes, Lizzo. (crowd cheers and claps)
Because before Lizzo, there was no Lizzo.
That's true.
The Grammy winning rapper, singer, actor
and total charm machine says she blazed her own path
with one goal in mind, showing the world
that this is what success can look like.
And she wants to embrace and empower
women all over the world who identify with her,
who might not think they fit in the mold
and she's gonna blast right through that mold.
Yes, she is.
This is so awesome.
It's so awesome, and Lizzo just proves
that if you don't fit the mold,
then break the mold, make your own mold, right.
Right? Yes. (crowd cheers and claps)
And so many women do that, you know,
and this issue celebrates game changers across every field
like Emily Penn who's an ocean activist
who started Expedition, an all women sailing
research team that fights ocean pollution
and Monica Johnson in Louisiana.
Her nonprofit, Heroes, offers medical care,
counseling and professional training
to HIV positive members of her community.
So, there are women all over this country
making such a difference.
(crowd claps)
I'm such a People magazine fan.
I subscribe to it, I get it every week.
Mm-hmm.
And I wanna thank them for for shining the spotlight
on these amazing women
'cause this issue is on news stands now.
And it actually leads me to a pick
from "Drew's Little Yellow Book",
which is my personal curation.
(crowd cheers and claps)
But this is something very personal to me.
This is "Good Night Stories for Rebel Girls",
and I'm reading this with my daughters right now.
There's actually two volumes
and they're just great historical confirmations
that there's nothing women can't do.
Hey, how about that.
(upbeat theme music)